people want certainty about their lives
and their future uncertainty about the
future of the loved ones and I'm
speaking here about 3.5 million citizens
in the UK who came from a European Union
member states and about run round about
1 million British people living
elsewhere in the European Union now
these are large numbers but behind each
of these numbers are people with their
very own personal stories this with
rural agreement and with what we have
agreed on puts of course clear
obligations on the United Kingdom and on
the European Union to safeguard these
rights one thing is to put them on paper
and the other thing is to implement them
so once the house has ratified the
withdrawal agreement our top priority
will be to implement our shared
obligations both in letter and in spirit
the implementation of the withdrawal
agreement matters because it provides a
minimum of legal certainty people need
we regret that in spite of the option
presented in article 18 point 4 of the
withdrawal agreement the UK has chosen
to use the application approach for
settled stay to scheme I regret also
that only half of member states seem to
use the approach based on declaration we
also deeply regret that the UK
government has announced its intention
to end free movement of people and the
future framework for cooperation the UK
government can do more and should do
more to ensure full protection of
citizens rights in the context of praxic
but it truth is that the u settlement
scheme currently in operation the UK
could easily easily be more
user-friendly and would largely benefit
with additional assistance provided to
older and more vulnerable citizens there
are still concerns dear colleagues
concerns that needs to be dressed and if
they are not dressed now before the end
of the month there will be on the table
the Tory government has always say he
wants less bureaucracy well okay let's
make less bureaucracy and the best way
to do it is an automatic recognition
why not putting a few representatives of
the three million organization and the
independent monitoring authority then we
are sure that both sides are there so
then that that solves the the problem no
some separe a to fair poor limite Oh
stick minimum lega lega area ocasion a
parlor righto hominid or anewhopeee a
massage nominee else we receive mo you
consider hey Luna hope en come in prison
ami de hominid a VA hospital attitude
vis-a-vis it well hope a vocal firm a -
supremacist attitude ami je a catalyst
it we are European hegemony converse
with echolalia Britannic only don't in
Europeans what had a person the Duke
attended was su system a leakin seconds
ready Dakota very very pretty
the consequence direct the rasa precio
de la liberté no circulation que tu caja
de béxar
residual herbicide a certitude catalonia
Lavinia de la familia y is always water
savoir secure breaks its in Evo Donna
vacati Jenna in addition to dissident
rights there are many many other topics
where we must remain vigilant included
in this withdrawal agreement and I am
thinking in particular about the
protocol on Ireland and Northern Ireland
which grantees integrative single market
but also preserves the old Ireland
economy and prevents the return of odd
border